just been added a piece of paper  which says that fuel has gone up again  in the last 24 hours yesterday i was  telling you  um that fuel was 178 for petrol  and 185 for diesel it's just gone up  again um 180 now for petrol octupants in  just 24 hours diesel at 186 so that's  gone up more than a penny in the last 24  hours currently costs to fill a 55 liter  family car that's already more than 100  pounds if you use um diesel um unleaded  is 99 pounds 40 for a 55 litre vehicle  that's definitely going to go above  100 pounds as a result of those latest  figures  we were speaking to the petrol retailers  association earlier on and they said the  government needs to do something to help  motorists and is appealing for another  cut in fuel duty